if you want to see a holiday special
that Disney Plus know you heard here
first I framed my Mandalorian coin oh
you did a good Reem did in my apartment
oh good okay
congratulations a lot of people watching
this tonight want to be filmmakers as
well what advice would you have for
young I say there's nothing preventing
you from doing it now and that's what's
different than when I started off when
you had to get get to rent cameras you
had to rent media and Avid's and you had
to get film stock and processing now you
could you know it might not be ready for
the multiplex but you could make movies
on your phone you could cut them on your
computer and you can get better and
better as a storyteller and I just work
with Donald Glover who you know started
off filmmaking with YouTube videos so
there's ways to self distribute there's
ways to to have your story be told and
as you get better and more recognized
those opportunities will grow but
there's nothing preventing you from
getting better and doing what you love
right now
now I want to call it somebody very
special because Gina Carano can you come
on OK
John how much am I gonna fall in love
with cardoon hi um I'm jeana's biggest
fan
Gina is just a wonderful actor to watch
her do dialogue and scenes and and and
she's just incredibly fun to watch on
screen but when she falls into action
mode and she's such a wonderful athlete
and all of her training and all of her
background bring this authenticity to
her performance on the screen and not
only that but there's a joy and her eyes
light up when she's doing action and she
really genuinely loves it and I love
just even today we were looking cuz we
were doing we were doing a sound mix on
her episode and I was watching her and I
just keep remarking look at her smiling
while she's fighting she just has a fuse
as a blast so it's just so much fun to
watch
and usually people tell me to stop
smiling and I think with with John he
was just like bring you to the character
and that was awesome because I did I was
able to smile I was able to enjoy it and
I was able to build Cara Doon from me it
doesn't get much better than this
I like he's so you're so comfortable to
be around but I'm still constantly just
starts talking like it's just amazing
like the best person to work with in the
world right yeah that's very thank you
so much and we're and it is really fun
the whole cast was having a blast and
look we all get to do Star Wars like
that's that the bottom line for me is
like I never thought that this would be
even in the car it's when I was you know
a little kid watching the first film and
now here we are telling you stories with
a bunch of people who've already worked
with Star Wars like the people at
Lucasfilm and ILM and Dave Filoni and
they're sort of indoctrinating us into
the understanding the depth of the genre
but then to bring my sense of humor my
style my sense of action her personality
her skill set it's something that's
really exciting and fun I think people
are gonna really dig it yeah and it's
November it's it's you know in the panel
I know you know what you're doing you
know Star Wars but Dave phony was
bringing up some like deep cut stuff
like but like the holiday special did he
give you like very specific home I was
the one who was bringing the holiday
special the table
that's my generation I love the holiday
special I mean in a you know certain
sequences more than others yeah but I
love the introduction of Boba Fett and
that rifle that he had that animated
piece still holds up it's pretty cool
and I draw inspiration from that and you
know I would I would love to do some day
maybe on Disney plus we'll do a holiday
special too I got a pitch that if you
want to see a holiday special that
Disney Plus know you heard here first
you like something you let them know
wait to me here thank you guys